hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the universal genetic code and how
it is used to convert information store
in DNA into protein first let's talk
about what the genetic code is it's
simply a set of rules a set of
instructions if you will that the cell
uses to get information that is encoded
in genetic material into protein it's
kind of like a language as we'll see so
the genetic code helps information that
is encoded within mRNA to be converted
into protein and again the process
through which that happens is
translation so let's look at how it
works
cells have information that is stored
within DNA this is why DNA is the
genetic material of cells the phonetic
information gets transcribed into RNA
and then translated into protein so this
process this movement of genetic
information from DNA to protein through
an RNA intermediate is known as the
central dogma of molecular biology if
you're interested in learning more about
the central dogma see my video on that
topic now here we have a DNA sequence
made of the nucleotides thymine adenine
cytosine and guanine this here is the
template strand so it's the strand of
DNA that is going to be used in
transcription to make the strand of mRNA
and so this is done by complementary
base pairing between nucleotides
remember that in the process of
transcription because there is no
thymine in RNA the other nucleotides are
the same
adenine guanine and cytosine but since
there's no thymine we use uracil to base
pair with the a demeans so here we have
our mRNA strand the genetic code works
off of nucleotide triplets that means
that a set of three nucleotides which is
called a codon each codon codes for an
amino acid so for example a u G is one
codon and it codes for the amino acid
methionine if we continue down the line
to the next codon you Gigi this codes
for tryptophan and again
cau this is the third coat on it codes
for histidine a you a codes for
isoleucine a cg codes for threonine GC a
codes for alanine and hi let me get to
you AG u AG is special because it is a
stop codon it is what tells the
translation process to terminate the
ongoing process so that no more amino
acids are added so u AG is one of three
different stop codons Aug from a
thiamine is known as the start codon
that's because Aug is at the beginning
of every mrna sequence and it codes the
first amino acid which is always meth
ine
of course methionine can also be used
within the protein chain but it's always
found at the beginning so that is the
difference between
and stop codons I also want to briefly
talk about the effect of mutations
notice how the codon code to the
triplets that we use to convert from the
nucleotides to the amino acids it is
considered non-overlapping that means
the first three nucleotides apart codon
one then the second set of three
nucleotides is codon to the third set of
three nucleotides is codon three rather
than the codons moving like a GU GU GU T
etc which would be overlapping so the
code is non overlapping however if you
have a point mutation that is a change
in one nucleotide that can affect which
amino acid is eventually plugged in to
the growing polypeptide chain so for
example in a missense mutation this is
when the nucleotide changes so that a
different amino acid is plug into the
polypeptide chain a nonsense mutation is
when one of these codons changes in such
a way that rather than coding for an
amino acid it codes for a stop codon for
example here you Gigi goes for
tryptophan but if there were a mutation
that changed this G to an a of course
when we say a mutation we mean something
that happens in the original DNA strand
but if it alters this to you
G a that is a kind of stop codon so we
would have a stop codon here and that
would be called a truncation so an early
truncation that results in a truncated
polypeptide because translation was
terminated too early
even more severe type of mutation as
frameshift mutation and that occurs when
there's an insertion or deletion of
nucleotides so if in the original DNA
sequence there is an insertion or
deletion of one or two nucleotides
that's going to throw off all of the
codons because of that non-overlapping
codon language you can imagine that if
there were just one or two nucleotides
inserted in here that we're extra due to
mutation that would throw off all of the
later amino acids they would all be read
incorrectly I also want to talk about
something very special in the genetic
code and this is its redundancy you
often hear this called as degeneracy
this is because with the genetic code if
you look at the table that shows which
codons could for which amino acids
you'll see that there are actually 64
codons that's because there are 64
different combinations of the four
nucleotides in codon triplets
however these 64 codons they only code
for 20 amino acids this means that there
are several codons that can be used to
code for just one amino acid and this
leads us to something known as the
wobble hypothesis that is that in most
cases not all but most the third letter
of the codon doesn't actually matter
that means that as long as the first two
are correct the third one in many cases
can be any one of the nucleotides and
you'll still get the right amino acid
down here and that's because of that
redundancy in the
like code now the reason that this is
important is because it basically means
that mutations in the third spot of the
codon are not as likely to affect the
actual amino acid being plugged in to
the polypeptide chain now before we end
let's talk about a couple of exceptions
to the genetic code one of the cool
things about the genetic code is that it
is used by virtually all living
organisms it's one of those pieces of
evidence for the common descent of all
life from one previous ancestor however
there are a few organisms that have
developed some changes over time for
example eukaryotic cells use methionine
as their start codon so Aug is the start
codon methionine is the first amino acid
plugged into the polypeptide chain
whereas bacteria on the other hand tend
to use a kind of modified methionine
formyl methionine the formal group on
the methionine and you know acid in
those bacteria many times it can be
removed in post translational
modifications but that is a modification
that's been picked up by many bacteria
also stop codons versus non-standard
amino acids the stop codons there are
three of them used by most living things
in certain organisms one or two of those
stop codons may actually code for a
non-standard amino acid so not one of
the 20 that we think of as canonical
amino acids with things like Celino
cysteine and pyro lysine that are only
used in a few different organisms and
those are simply evolutionary
modifications so that is it for our
discussion of the universal genetic code
I hope you learned a lot and thanks for
watching biology professor